Picard season 4 rumors persist but what
is the actual truth welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
so I actually had an email from one of
my subscribers yesterday saying look
another YouTuber is saying Picard season
4 is in the works happening it's in
development is it true no it isn't
pecan season 4 has been talked about by
people like ikiva goldsman Patrick stews
himself has even said he would return to
Star Trek if there was the right story
and he feels that there is much more
story to tell Jonathan Frakes has also
gone on record as saying that he would
love to return as reiker and sorry so
many of the other one says like Gates
McFadden houses as well etc etc
it does seem that there is more appetite
from the public for more of the Next
Generation crew in all honesty I love
Picard season three even though I have
just done a video saying that I watched
it a second time and it's not as good
second time around it loses a lot of the
Nostalgia a lot of the The Joy from you
know like things seeing things like the
Enterprise day
um the plot holes are heavy when you
actually watch it a second time so don't
do that but I still loved it and it's
still much better than everything else
that Star Trek has done recently
would I love another series of that yes
of course I would but to be honest
Picard season 3 shouldn't have really
been called Picard it should have been
called Star Trek Legacy or something
like that it didn't really center around
Picard like the first two seasons did it
centered far more around the Next
Generation crew as an ensemble cast
really picardo is nothing like his
pivotal as he was in the first two
seasons a nice way of ending it would
have been if they'd have renamed the
Titan the Picard at least that would
have made more sense that the show was
then called Picard but anyway
I mentioned Star Trek Legacy there
because if we are going to get a fourth
season of Picard it will be the Star
Trek Legacy show but what do we actually
know about that well obviously Terry
metallis has talked about it quite a lot
he said that this was something he would
love to do he's obviously set it up in
the end of Picard season three with the
the cute little bit of the end spoiler
curiously in this card season three if
you've not seen it Q Mays will have
actually have said Jack get ready mate
we're getting another series but he
didn't he just sort of said you know the
trial never ends now it's your turn so
it's very clearly set up for another
show based aboard the Titan that they
now call the Enterprise G
Ives a stupid decision
seven of nine is Captain and Jack is
whatever he is he's an Ensign but I have
no idea what his job title is special
consultant to the captain or something I
don't know
um and it does seem that that is very
very likely Alex kurtzman has even come
out since and said or we've heard the
fans we are listening which is a massive
hint that actually yes
CBS Paramount
secret hideout Etc have plans to do
Legacy now I've actually spoken to a
couple of my sources that work in and
around this industry and Paramount and
they've said this was always the plan
Paramount did this before they do a
little bit of a bait and switch on us
they did this with strange new worlds
strange new worlds was always planned to
be a standalone series when Anson Mount
joined Discovery season two as Captain
Pike it was always the plan that there's
going to be a spin-off series of
strengths new worlds that they did it
they waited a bit and then they
pretended that it was Paramount
listening to the fans because Star Trek
has a little bit of a PR problem
Discovery wasn't massively popular the
first two seasons of Picard weren't
massively popular and one way that they
thought of trying to get the fans back
on board was basically doing this
Act that they were then listening to the
fans and we've got strange new worlds
just because of the fans it's a very
clever strategy that my guy who works in
the industry says they're doing again we
are getting Star Trek Legacy it's when
not if it probably will be about two
years it might be announced after the
end of Discovery but he said it's
probably more likely to be announced
after the section 31 movie
so
we are not getting Picard season 4
however much the rumors continue it's
just not going to happen
but Picard might return Patrick's Judas
said so and I believe he will I believe
much of the crew of The Next Generation
will return Geordie data Riker Troy and
so on
but it will be as part of Star Trek
Legacy now we might get to see them in
one or two of these spin-off movies that
they're talking about and we know that
section 31 is going to be the first of
these straight to TV movies
but Alex curtemus said they want to do
that every two years so perhaps the
movie in a couple of years time
following section 31 will be something
next Generation like with some of the
actors from that series Will Patrick
Stewart appear in that
he's an old man let's see how his health
holds up but I am absolutely certain if
he is healthy and able he would be
willing
so maybe that is what they're talking
about and maybe that is the movie The
Next Generation movie that they keep
hinting might be on the cards so yeah
look
the video in particular that my
subscriber was talking about actually
didn't necessarily say in the video that
Star Trek Picard season 4 was actually
on the cards he was very careful to sort
of dance around that but his tail was
100 click baited he 100 says exclusive
Picard season 4 in works now I get
moaned up for clickbaiting from time to
time my tiles and my titles they're
actually not very easy to write you've
only got a few words you've got to make
them short and punch you've got to try
and make it sound like somebody actually
wants to listen to the damn video
um but also you know you haven't got
many words there to describe you can't
say here is a video about Picard season
4 that it is not in the works but
um actually it might be in a way because
it's going to be called Star Trek Legacy
and that was always the plan anyway that
can't be your title because it's just
stupid
so it can be very difficult but doing a
tile that says exclusive Picard season 4
in works is clickbaiting and to be
honest it's a bit naughty but guys tell
me what you think Picard season 4 Star
Trek Legacy same thing or should Star
Trek Legacy be Star Trek the next
Generations Next Generation should it
move away from the TNG crew maybe the
odd Cameo here and there but no more
than that is it time for this crew to
stand aside after a brilliant send-off
for Picard season three and a new crew
to join the history of the Enterprise
get to the comments and tell me exactly
what you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports a channel you get to see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
foreign